now millie's comments were shocking but
not to the media who sees where
political power currently resides
millie delivered a sermon on anti-racism
and pro-intellectualism it was great to
hear the general
reinforce the point that more people
need to learn people need to
uh actually educate themselves it was so
bracing it was so encouraging
general milli got to be applauded not
only today but every single day that he
goes to work
joining me now independent journalist
glenn greenwald
glenn i mean now i've seen it all
i've seen the far left and liberals and
phony conservatives
now come to the military's defense
even when the military appears to be
getting
very very political your reaction to all
of this
well first of all when as journalists do
we celebrate
the military and not just anyone in the
military but
the top military official the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
weighing in on extremely polarizing
cultural and political debates and
applauding him for doing so it's exactly
what we want the military
not to do secondly the
question about why would the military
suddenly
embrace what is essentially leftist
cultural dogma
not something we're accustomed to seeing
the military do over the last
seven or eight decades to put that
mildly is i think a really interesting
question
and if you look laura at what the
military posture is under the biden
administration they very much
want to initiate a new war on terror one
that's aimed domestically
and their identified enemy are not
isis or al qaeda or russia or china or
anything like that they say the gravest
threat to national security
are domestic extremists and specifically
white supremacists so by
embracing this kind of doctrine that
says that
white supremacy is pervasive throughout
the society what that general is really
doing is justifying
this domestic war on terror as all of
these journalists applaud him for doing
so it's really quite an amazing
spectacle
yeah well and going through social media
they've already said that that they have
to do that in order to tamp down
on domestic terror and extremism when
they use such a broad term
uh that's frankly meaningless the word
extremism what does that mean
extreme to whom on what basis what are
their objective metrics for determining
extremism
and you see you see these msnbc hoes
kind of like
oh this is so great like they're like
the bobby soxers of
2021 with uh with millie by the way cnn
is not going to surprise you is
justifying
general milly's comments with another
general watch
he's faced with extremism in the ranks
he's faced with an
enemy that is based on white rage so
what he's doing is studying them he's
trying to get to know the enemy what
and he said this what caused this white
rage
how do you define it and how do you
eliminate it from within the military
ranks
glenn i guess white people are the only
ones who can get enraged these days
and i just i can't even believe i'm
hearing these words come out of former
military current military
now the uh the enemy is us meaning the
people
well i think i mean i think that's the
key point you know i think a lot of
people who
cheered for the war on terror and the
immediate aftermath of 9 11 came
to understand that when you vest immense
power
in the hands of the government in the
name of fighting a war that's very
amorphous against terrorism
it can lead to a lot of abuses and it's
very hard to end it once it begins
now we're talking about doing exactly
the same thing but this time directed
inward at the our own citizenry and
there are very few things
more dangerous as you say than
empowering the government to wage a
domestic war against its own citizenry
without extremely restrictive
constraints on who they're targeting and
all they're saying is
we're going after extremists and not
just extremists but white extremists
in particular and the other really
disturbing part is general barry
mccaffrey who's a four-star general who
now works at nbc news
came on and said your colleague tucker
carlson other people at fox news
including yourself
who criticized general milley ought to
be fired immediately
as though now it's off limits to even
critique
military officials i suppose in the name
of democracy but these people who have
babbled about fascism for five years are
now cheering generals
demanding that journalists be fired for
the crime
of criticizing generals when they
intervene in our politics it's a really
disturbing climate that's being created
meanwhile after 20 plus years uh we were
not able to
overcome the taliban don't think he has
bigger bigger
things that he should be worrying about
uh glenn great to see you thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else